Happy 5th of July I hope everybody had a
good Independence Day
I know it's easy these days to feel down
on America because our government is so
corrupt
that's why I was so pleased to kick off
Fourth of July weekend with some
excellent and unexpected news
after years of watching leftists get
away with political violence against
conservatives I learned late last week
that two antifa anarchists have been
arrested by the FBI and they've been
charged by the doj and they're facing
potentially a decade in prison for
hurling an explosive in my direction at
the University of Pittsburgh turns out
the rockets red glare the bombs bursting
in air if proof through the night that
our flag is still there I'm Michael
knowlesist Michael Knowles show
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by good
ranchers get great meat at a secure
price and 30 bucks off your order with
my code Knowles kwlas go to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles today
Hunter Biden's child Joe Biden's seventh
grandchild that he won't acknowledge is
becoming a major political liability for
him in 2024 and apparently Biden's
senior staff are now telling the White
House aides never to acknowledge this
child we'll get to that in one second
because it's not only a political
liability finally for him but it's also
like the worst thing the guy has done as
far as I'm concerned he destroyed the
economy he sent us hurtling toward World
War III but just on a personal level to
deny your little four-year-old
grandchild is just so awful so we'll get
to that in a second first though I don't
want to move too fast off this Anarchist
story this is really really great news
and there's some backstory here which
I've never talked about on the air but I
I gave my speech or my my debate at the
University of Pittsburgh and there's a
ton of publicity around it I was
supposed to debate this
professor and we were going to debate
the question what is a woman who decides
where does sex and gender come from that
sort of thing at the very last moment he
pulls out of the debate
because
I just think he realized he didn't have
a leg to stand on so he pulls out at the
very last moment and Brad Palumbo who's
a Libertarian gay identify not McKay
identifying uh political commentator he
pinched pinch hit at the last moment
which is very nice of him and there were
all sorts of threats on the debate there
were petitions from legislators everyone
trying to shut this thing down and then
there was a major protest outside of the
debate so we get to the venue these
people are not just holding their signs
with their stupid chance they're setting
the street on fire they burned me in
effigy they're shedding all sorts of
threats uh the cops lead us in the back
you know we're backstage about to go on
as we go on stage an explosive goes off
and so you hear the building kind of
shakes a little bit you hear this big
explosive the cops send us back into the
green room while they secure what's
going on over there eventually I said
look I want to keep going I don't care
what what's going on outside let's go
we're doing this thing we're not going
to let these guys shut us up so we go
there were a lot of threats throughout
the whole event they tried to end it
early we just kept plowing on finally
they they did have to cancel our meet
and greet afterward but we get out of
there do the full debate okay fine I
then get a message through my assistant
uh which was that the FBI wanted to
interview me because the FBI just
happened to be at my debate and wanted
to bring charges against these antifa
people and I thought you know I'm very
pro-law enforcement I've I've Got
Friends who've worked for the FBI I know
lots of lots of great people who have
worked for the FBI in years past
wouldn't have thought anything of it
would have happily
spoken voluntarily to the FBI but then I
thought you know
just a few weeks before I got this
request
there was a memorandum that came out
that showed the FBI was trying to
infiltrate conservative Catholic
parishes called Conservative Catholics a
domestic Terror threat you know a little
bit before that the FBI knocks on the
door of a pro-life Advocate and and
arrests him in front of his seven kids
for just for being a pro-life Advocate I
thought that's not good this is the FBI
that had had illegitimately gone after
Trump on completely bogus charges spied
on his campaign did the Dirty Work of of
the Democrats and Barack Obama I thought
you know
this is the FBI that set up Mike Flynn
on nothing I thought you know I don't
know I don't know that I trust
the FBI and the doj certainly not under
Joe Biden I'm good I don't really
believe that they're going to bring
charges against antifa and I'm really
pleased to say I was wrong
I was really surprised to see it but
they not only did the FBI arrest these
guys but then the doj U.S attorneys
brought charges against them it's a
husband and a wife they're not kids by
the way there was one time I was
attacked at the University of Missouri
Kansas City by some weirdo with a squirt
gun full of who knows what and
when I did speak to the cops after that
and they said you know okay do you have
any statement and I said look I don't
really want to encourage you guys to
press charges if it's just some stupid
kid I don't want to ruin his life
because he just is an idiot even if he
attacked me I don't know whatever you
know who cares uh and no to which the
cops then told me uh no Michael he
punched a police officer that he's got
bigger problems than you so I said okay
but it's a kid doesn't matter these guys
this husband and wife from Pittsburgh
that threw the explosive
they're in there one of them is 36 years
old one of them is 40 years old so these
are not spring chickens these are
hardened criminal radical leftists and
after watching the George Floyd riots
gone for months and months and months
the cops do nothing because the
political leaders told them they could
do nothing after watching all sorts of
lawlessness encouraged by our political
establishment meanwhile law enforcement
is weaponized by the Liberals to go
after ordinary conservatives I'm just
very pleased I want to want to give
credit where credits do good job to the
FBI good job to the doj now I hope
I hope that these two don't get off with
a little slap on the wrist
I hope this isn't all just a big PR
stunt and then they don't need to really
worry about anything
the fact that these guys through their
explosive not just in my direction but
there was something in between them and
me and that thing would happen to be a
bunch of police officers I think that
might have elevated the case here and so
because of that I hope they face some
serious punishment they're looking at up
to 10 years in prison
and they deserve it we've got to show
the radical left that we're not going to
tolerate their political violence
especially not political violence on a
college campus especially not political
violence against people for holding an
open debate on a basic question so good
job now let's make sure they see it
through when the political order gets
crazy you know what you want to do
you're going to want to have some
tangible assets you're going to want to
check out
Birch gold right now text Knowles to 98
98 98 is central banks in countries like
China India and Australia begin looking
to transition to a digital currency the
Federal Reserve has been contemplating
the same for the U.S with a digital
currency the government could track
every single purchase you make officials
could even prohibit you from purchasing
certain products or easily freeze or
seize part or all of your money Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold you can do that with the help of
Birch gold they are who I buy my gold
from so do thousands of other concern
Savers Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't pay a penny out of pocket
when currencies fail gold is a safe
haven how much more time does the Dollar
have protect your savings with gold
Birch gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers
next Knowles to 98 98.98 get your free
info kit on gold at the Central Bank
digital currency becomes a reality it's
going to be nice to have some gold to
depend upon right now text Knowles
Canada wies to 98 98 98. speaking of the
Courts
really great decision came out of the
Supreme Court the hits just keep on
coming you know we talked about how the
Supreme Court struck down affirmative
action we'll get to more on that story
in just a moment because you know I hate
to say I told you so one of my big
predictions about that case has already
been proven true but there was another
great case which was over religious
liberty Court ruled 6-3 that a web
designer
who did not want to participate in a
quote-unquote gay wedding ceremony will
not have to do so that this woman has a
First Amendment right not to use her
creative services to participate in a
ceremony that violates her moral views
this is a 6-3 decision so what it's not
even a five four it's not even like
Robert's sided with the libs or anything
like this Gorsuch wrote the majority
opinion
and said no not only
do Colorado bakers not have to bake
gay wedding cakes or whatever but web
designers also don't need to contribute
their creative Services their language
their their intellectual work to these
ceremonies that they believe are not
only incoherent and absurd but also
violate their moral views great news and
it's popular
forget about the law for a second
because there have been all sorts of
Lawless Supreme Court decisions
decisions that came down that
established a constitutional precedent
that had nothing to do with the
Constitution or the law natural or civil
uh
I think another reason why this decision
came down is because it's popular
most people don't think that you should
be forced to participate in a sexual
ceremony that you find morally
objectionable the vast majority of
Americans think that this is the first
pride month in my lifetime
where pride has become less popular
you saw it with Bud Light you saw with
Target you saw it with
even Cracker Barrel is getting Flack for
for embracing the rainbow
that wasn't true for my whole life
starting in the 90s
accelerating with the popularity of Will
and Grace
then EX in recent years everything just
gets painted with a rainbow for at least
a month this year
there was a lot of pushback you're
seeing this reflected in American Social
views Pew has reported this Gallup has
reported on this Gallup showed that
Americans views of same-sex relations
have dropped not just marriage or
whatever but relations period have
dropped seven points in one year
so the court looks at the polls the
court reads the news and the court
discovered that this Pride stuff is very
unpopular that's why Republicans need to
keep pressing on this because what we
were told in those early days of the
pride movement was this is just about
tolerance and acceptance and leave us
alone and how does it affect you and
keep your nose out of people's bedrooms
and whatever but that's never what it
was about the the inevitable logical
conclusion of the pride movement was
we're going to go into your kids
kindergarten and we're going to teach
them wild ideologies about sex and
gender and and not only the relations
between the Sexes and within the Sexes
but even one's understanding of human
nature itself and
people have just said enough enough with
that uh
the DeSantis campaign is capitalizing on
this right now and DeSantis is being
pilloried not just by the libs but by
the squishes on the right for an ad that
people are saying is homophobic here's
the ad
from hanging out with Bruce Jenner
holding up a rainbow flag any bathroom
she choose is that is correct in the
future can transgender women compete in
Lady Gaga yes
drag queen
and then DeSantis comes in just says no
this is all these like Sigma male memes
Patrick Bateman DeSantis signs a
Draconian anti-lgbt bill
the Sanderson acts of wave of laws you
see the Chad meme guy like super strong
guy he has shut down DeSantis
Unstoppable just some of the harshest
most Draconian laws that literally
threaten trans existence congratulations
Rhonda Sanders mission accomplished you
win
oh
this Governor does not care to sand its
on a crusade
a real wolf had finally arrived Wall
Street so really leaning into this
online Sigma mail socially conservative
no we're not going to tolerate this
rainbow Pride stuff anymore
I think it's a great ad I think it's a
great ad one because it's funny
it's a self-aware ad I don't think
anybody really believes that Ron
DeSantis is going to be you know
instituting Sharia law and throwing home
sexuals off rooftops right nobody really
believes that but the ad with all of its
Sigma mail Patrick Bateman kind of
vaporwave aesthetic is is
showing people a real aspect of his
political Legacy and his accomplishments
which is we're not going to enshrine
special protections for this disordered
view of human nature we're going to be
nice to people we're going to tolerate
things within reason but and no we're
going to roll back the pride movement
that's now made it all the way into your
kids kindergarten classroom and it's
really really good and he's smart to go
after Trump on this because Trump is by
far the most pro-lgbt elementop
candidate that the GOP has ever run for
president and I don't think this is
because Trump is some Crusader for gay
rights or or anything like that I think
it's because Trump is just
he's just an old school normal guy who
doesn't really care about this stuff and
he kind of he's he's willing to Pander
to different groups to get their votes
but you know I don't I don't think you
could call him a rainbow activist or
anything like that the reason this is a
really good attack though on Donald
Trump is it gives the Republican base a
justification for abandoning Trump and
embracing DeSantis I'm not saying it's
going to work but it's one of the first
things that will give the base that
justification because right now
looking at the field the real hardcore
guys remain pro-trump
it's just a fact you might say that's
not fair you might say DeSantis is the
more conservative candidate maybe maybe
that's Ultra I don't know I'm just
saying the hardcore guys
remain pro-trump and the more GOP
establishment types if they've got to
pick between the two are going for Ron
DeSantis so DeSantis has this
establishment baggage even if it just
comes by virtue of the fact that he's
the guy who's posing a real challenge to
Trump right now he's got to deal with
that he has to somehow answer the fact
that the GOP establishment and the
mainstream establishment brought more
broadly is going softer on DeSantis than
they are on Trump this is one great way
to do it if he runs to the right of
trump on the social issues specifically
on the Rainbow Coalition that will give
the the hardcore guys an opportunity to
say actually if we really want to be
subversive if we really want to be edgy
we can
we're going to follow this guy who's
threatening the sexual Revolution which
the libs hold very very dear and the
other reason this works is because well
the establishment is very pro-rainbow
the the people broadly including many
Democrats are not this is a real wedge
issue between the elites of the uniparty
and the people brought it the few and
the many it's one of these great wedge
issues so really really strong stuff for
DeSantis now does an ad showing that
DeSantis is tougher on LGBT activism
than Trump does that make up a 30-point
gap I'm not sure about that but it is
still very early in the race so if there
is a chance for DeSantis this is
probably it this was a little bit the
cruise strategy in 2016. the crew
strategy was to say I am to the right
socially of Donald Trump
and actually they've focused on the
issue here because Donald Trump said
that people who identify as as the
opposite sex they can use whatever
bathroom they want to use and Ted Cruz
said see Donald Trump is uh a leftist on
the issue and I'm gonna insist that men
use the men's room and women use the
women's room and and because Trump got
the nomination people drew I think the
wrong conclusion from that which is they
say well okay this this socially
conservative strategy this is the best
way to become the first loser you know
this is the best way to come in number
two in the GOP race
the people forget the particulars of
this had the rest of the field dropped
out had Marco Rubio dropped out before
Florida Ted Cruz almost certainly would
have been the GOP nominee in 2016. now
you might say well Cruz would have lost
to Hillary I don't know what would have
happened in the general I'm just telling
you about the primary that was a very
close primary until Trump finally broke
away right there at the end so if if
DeSantis follows the cruise social
conservative strategy
in a race where there were fewer
candidates many fewer serious candidates
in 2016 there were 20 guys on the stage
and they all had kind of roughly the
same chance at different points right
now that's not true there were two three
maybe four candidates who can pose a
real threat here and so if if DeSantis
can rally that anti-trump support and
then he pursues something akin to the
cruise strategy in 2016. it's not
necessarily the worst idea
so with DeSantis potentially finding
some light here and being able to gain
some ground what what's going on with
the rest of the field the rest of the
field is going after DeSantis you saw
this uh just now with Chris Christie you
know I've talked about my dark horse bet
that Chris Christie could really have a
moment in this race and I know everyone
mocks me forward talking about the
chrysosons the croissants we call it for
short but
uh if I were even allowed to BET
unpredicted right now predict it's not
even showing Chris Christie in the GOP
Primary betting markets I'd put a small
amount of money on it because I think he
could he could have a blip at least a
moment Christy is not going after Trump
right now he's going after
Ron DeSantis specifically over January
6th
I wasn't anywhere near Washington that
day I have nothing to do with what
happened that day obviously I didn't
enjoy seeing you know what what happened
but we've got to go forward on this
stuff we cannot be looking backwards and
be mired in the past he talked a little
bit before that about how Biden is
running for office and why he or Biden
running and why he should defeat him but
is that the way you think Republicans
should be answering that question on
January the 6th he wasn't anywhere near
Washington did he have a TV
Was he alive that day
did he see what was going on
I mean that's one of the most ridiculous
answers I've heard in this race so far
you don't have an opinion about January
6th
except to say I didn't particularly
enjoy
what happened
people were killed exactly a strong
statement people were killed people were
killed that's true well one person was
killed the one person who was killed in
the political violence of that day was a
trump supporter who was killed by a
trigger-happy cop that's the part that
Chris Christie leaves out there
but it's it's a smart attack for Christy
because Christie's running a kind of a
Kamikaze campaign
where he's theoretically trying to go
after Donald Trump but he knows if he
wants to stay in long enough to go after
Trump he's got to take out Ron DeSantis
and this is the key this is probably the
biggest advantage that Trump has in 2024
which we'll get to in one second first
though I want to tell you about great
delicious meat I want to tell you about
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchors.com use promo code knows if
you have not yet heard the FDA has
approved lab-grown chicken for sale
yeah meet formed in a lab will soon be
coming to a store near you
yuck if you prefer real meat grown in a
pasture instead of a petri dish then you
need good ranchers not only do they sell
real meat from real animals but they
sell the best meat that this country has
to offer from Steakhouse quality cuts of
beef to better than organic chicken
everything good Rancher sources is from
local farms in America plus right now
you'll get 30 off with my code Knowles
Canada wlas goodranchers.com they've got
terrific products top tier customer
service you can't call the scientists in
the lab to ask about their fake meat but
good ranchers has a team of people
available for you to call and answer all
your questions real meat real service
top stuff on the market I just
absolutely love their products what are
you waiting for enjoy real meat real
service today with good ranchers
goodranchors.com use code knows for 30
bucks off any box promo code Knowles at
goodranchers.com goodranchers.com
American meat delivered
it sometimes feels as though the current
culture is perfectly aligned to make you
stupid
when liberalism permeates every aspect
of your life it's really difficult to
know where to turn to
for guidance so I've got some good news
our friend
Dennis Prager is back with additional
episodes of prageru master's program
we've released the first five episodes
earlier this year audiences loved it
sparked a ton of conversation online
Dennis offers useful advice on marriage
happiness how to be a good person plus
so much more he even dares to explain
the differences between men and women in
the world and wants to make you a big
lib Dennis Prager is on a mission to
make you wise our latest episode picks
up by sharing more of the differences
between the left and the right a few of
them might just surprise you it's
available now for daily wire Plus
members with new episodes coming out
every week go to dailywire.com subscribe
to become a member and watch prageru's
master's program along with so much more
content daily wire.com subscribe today
Christy is going after DeSantis because
if DeSantis remains strong then none of
the other candidates are going to have a
chance to really take their shot at the
cane at Donald Trump
which means that the candidates are
going to focus their fire onto the
santis
which means Trump is going to maintain
his big league it probably is not going
to help the the lower polling candidates
it could hurt DeSantis we've already
seen the Santa's numbers go down that is
why this nomination
is set up in such a way
that Donald Trump has the overwhelming
likelihood of becoming the nominee and I
talked to many people around the country
I'm on the road constantly and they say
oh you know I just wish Trump would get
out of this thing I hope you I wish you
would drop out and some people still
love Trump by the way I don't want to
under sell that either there are a lot
of people who still love Trump they're
gung-ho they want him to have another
four years but the ones who say oh I
wish it were some other candidate maybe
DeSantis or somebody like that why won't
he just drop out the reason he won't
just drop out
is because if you were telling yourself
that Trump is not going to be the
nominee because of some prosecution or
because he is
too much of a loudmouth or something
like that you are fooling yourself you
are crazy this nomination is Trump's
nomination to lose by a country mile
I'm not saying he can't lose it I'm not
saying some other candidate can't pop up
but right now it is not even close and
the the primary is
the circumstances of them are just such
right now that
all of the incentives are for the other
candidates to take out DeSantis not
Trump now speaking of some of the other
candidates
you know
there's a candidate here who he and I go
back to college together he was at the
law school when I was in an
undergraduate and a lot of people didn't
know who he was when he announced that
he was running and I said hey
don't underestimate this guy
and some people said oh he's this guy
he's an entrepreneur he's the Andrew
Yang of 2024 GOP Primary
I said I wouldn't compare him to Andrew
yang this guy's a lot sharper he's a lot
more focused he's a lot more disciplined
a campaigner
this guy could go somewhere
a lot of people laughed you know I hate
to say I told you so
he's going somewhere Vivek ramaswamy has
just broken double digits in the
Republican primary race according to
Echelon insights which is a serious
polling firm
the poll found as I have said for a long
time that Donald Trump has a strong lead
he's got 49 support
DeSantis is only at 16 support right now
so now Trump has opened up the Gap it's
not just in the 20s anymore it's not
just 30 31 it's not 33 point gap
and then ramaswamy comes in
third
that's pretty when you think about how
many people are in the race you've got
multiple Governors you've got
Governor Nikki Haley governor ASA
Hutchinson who's kind of you know okay
whatever Governor Chris Christie you've
got a sitting U.S senator Tim Scott
you've got other candidates and then
this guy Vivek
this this Tech Pharma entrepreneur
anti-woke business guy who's got an
anti-woke asset management fund you know
he's kind of like a weirdo and he's come
out of nowhere because he's got a
message that appears to be resonating
with people
if anything goes wrong with the DeSantis
campaign DeSantis obviously a strong
number two right now
the vague has a real shot at being
[Music]
bumped up to number two and then who
knows who knows what happens from there
in any case though let's say you say all
right is it in double digits but he's
not going to go the distance
again wouldn't make predictions this far
out but let's let's say that were the
case
the vague has every incentive to stay in
this race his messages resonating his
numbers are rising and every moment he
stays in gives him a better opportunity
to if he loses the nomination to become
a cabinet pick to become
of running mate even potentially to to
have more power and influence over the
GOP and potentially over the
presidential ticket in 2024 all the
incentives are there and
the the influence just keeps Rising for
him
I mentioned that Blake and I go back to
college together
speaking of colleges the big Supreme
Court decision struck down affirmative
action
in college admissions
specifically against Harvard and UNC and
this case only really was able to go
through because the Discrimination was
directed not only toward white people
but also toward Asian students had this
just been about discriminating against
white people I don't think the court
would have struck it down because we
just live in a culture where white
people are denigrated they are not only
legally discriminated against but also
the culture encourages uniquely of white
people to be denigrated insulted called
you know the worst people in the world
and the courts read the newspapers and
they watch the election returns and I
think
probably affirmative action would have
remained in place
had it only been about white people but
the libs got greedy and they attacked
Asian people because Asians had the
highest test scores which really
undermines a lot of the narrative around
white privilege and whatever other
nonsense the lips talk about so because
this case could be framed as uh one
racial minority being oppressed
uh by I guess another racial minority
oppressor or something because the white
people didn't really factor into it too
much affirmative action gets struck down
and I celebrated this and I said wow
this is great news it had just broken
when I came on air but but I said you
know the one bit of caution I'll give
you here is
the schools are going to continue to
discriminate they're just going to do so
by reducing the importance of objective
measures and standardized tests and
they're going to inflate the importance
of say the personal statement and these
these more ambiguous criteria for
college admissions such that if you say
you know I am I am an oppressed person
black lives matter black lives matter in
your personal statement then that will
be given greater weight
and that's how the schools will continue
to discriminate against whites and
probably Asians too well
I really do hate to say I told you so
here Harvard already proved me right
within hours
Harvard sent out this notice dear
members of the Harvard community
today the Supreme Court delivered its
decision in students for fair admissions
versus president fellows of Harvard
College the Court held at Harvard
College admissions system does not
comply with the principles of the equal
protection Clause embodied in the title
title VI of the Civil Rights Act the
court also ruled that colleges and
universities
may consider in admissions decisions
quote an applicant's discussion of how
race affected his or her life be it
through discrimination inspiration or
otherwise
we will certainly comply with the
Court's decision
and there you go there it is
I I did not predict that they would
admit to this so openly
but they did it makes me feel good that
they basically said dear members of the
Harvard Community the thing Michael said
on his show is exactly what we're going
to do so I get a kick out of that I like
being right about these predictions but
that's really on the nose it's so Brazen
it's it's it makes a mockery of the
Supreme Court in the system of law and
that's amazing coming from one of our
nation's most prestigious universities
they would say yeah
an applicant we can ask an applicant to
discuss how race has affected his or her
life so you know that's what they're
going to put on the application now
say how okay we can't ask what race you
are or we can't force you to tell us
this and we can't we can't give weight
to you know if you're black you get an
extra 200 points or something if you're
a white or Asian you lose 200 points but
we can
give an outsize weight to this question
how has race affected your life and just
depending on how we feel about your
answer that's going to affect it so
Harvard is saying we are going to
continue to discriminate against white
people and against Asian people in
Admissions and Supreme Court you can go
pound sand they're saying this other
schools have been saying a similar thing
I think we've got another one here yeah
so this this uh some coverage this is
from Danielle Ren Holly president of
Mount Holyoke College
uh will it become more opaque this
application process yes it will have to
it's a complex process and this opinion
will make it even more complex I mean it
won't make it more complex than the
outcome which is whites and Asians will
be discriminated against uh black people
and other racial groups will have an
advantage and they're just going to do
it in a way that's a little bit more
complex they're going to have to ask a
long answer question instead of just
checking a box but that that will
continue and so forget about the college
admissions forget about the race uh
discrimination question for a second
this poses a great challenge to our
entire system of Law and Order and it
accelerates a trend that we've seen for
years now which is nobody has faith in
our system of law anymore nobody has
faith in our institutions and the
Republicans are blamed for this because
the Republicans are the
insurrectionists from January 6 the
worst day in American history but
more much more than the Republicans and
the conservative it's it's the Liberals
and the Democrats who have undermined
our system
of Law and Order and our political
institutions they've questioned many
more elections for far flimsier reasons
than the conservatives had from much
longer time they've undermined our
system of law and they've turned our
system of law which is supposed to be
primarily a matter of interpretation
interpreting
Eternal principles of Justice in the
natural law and applying them to
changing political circumstances in our
positive civil law they've changed that
to merely an act of the will no we're
not we're not going to say that there's
any objective moral order or natural law
or anything that's all bunk we're just
going to impose whatever the hell we
want through whatever legal mechanisms
we possibly can unjust though they may
be well by doing that you undermine our
our
faith in the system of justice the idea
that lady Justice is blind with her
scales no that's gone now Justice will
be meted out uh more intensely to
political enemies and more leniently to
political friends you see this even in
the construction of courtrooms
courtrooms used to be gigantic think of
the Supreme Court building in Washington
DC
big sturdy marble temples unchanging
heavy and now what are they they're tiny
little brutalist office rooms with low
ceilings where you don't feel that
weight of the law and the weight of
history and the unchanging
questions and principles of Justice
feels like any other bureaucrats office
where things can change on a diamond
frequently
they do and that's the libs doing that
and it's now being pushed by supposedly
one of the most prestigious colleges in
the country you can expect all the other
colleges to follow suit now there's
another lawsuit involving Harvard
which is a lawsuit to challenge the
practice of legacy admissions
so the court at least formally strikes
down affirmative action even if the
colleges are not going to comply with
that and the libs respond and they say
well there's there's affirmative action
for white people or for rich people or
for uh people with long histories at
these institutions and it's called
legacy admissions and so we're going to
try to strike that down too and a lot of
conservatives are cheering this on but
they are
sadly very misguided and they're buying
into the same silly principles that the
Liberals
have this is maybe my most unpopular
opinion on this issue but I'm very Pro
Legacy admission we'll get to why in a
second one of the main reasons why is we
need balance in our society and you need
balance in your body that's why you need
balance of nature right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure
that you are getting essential
nutritional ingredients every single day
through balance of Nature's Advanced
cold vacuum process the vitamins
minerals and phytonutrients of the
fruits and vegetables are preserved so
that you can get that vital nutrition in
each capsule balance of nature is a
whole food supplement with no additives
fillers extracts synthetics pesticides
added sugar none of that pure fruits and
veggies are the only things they put in
their capsules balance of nature sent a
bunch of their products down to the
studio for our team to try and these
absolute hyena jackals just ripped them
all apart these these monsters trying to
take them before I can get to them
that's not balance of Nature's fault
that's my team's fault we can deal with
that later when you are disciplined
enough to take care of your health you
reap all kinds of benefits your body
will thank you for a limited time this
summer when you become a preferred
customer balance of nature they're
throwing in a free fruit and veggies
travel set and giving you an additional
25 bucks off your first order go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knolls for a free travel set and 25
bucks off your first order is a
preferred customer balanceofnature.com
promo code Knowles my favorite comment
maybe ever but certainly from last week
is from Senor basson 4804
who says Michael is like if Dean Martin
took up politics
thank you very much I appreciate that I
was singing Volare and my walk into my
office today and I think the reason
you're saying that is because I've I've
got scotch in my tumbler every single
morning you know that's that's why
that's why I'm speaking in cursive by
the end of the show
the libs are going after legacy
admissions in colleges right now
the conservatives are squishing on this
and they think that they can find common
ground with the Liberals and they'll say
well actually you're right you know
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander and legacy admissions aren't
meritocratic either and we love
meritocracy and so yeah we'll go along
with that liberals but it's not it's not
a wise idea
at all you're never going to find middle
ground with the libs because they're
they're starting premises are so off and
two legacy admissions are good
they're good and very conservative
I was not a legacy admission to college
far from it I did not grow up with money
far from it
however I am very supportive of legacy
admissions for a few reasons one just
practically speaking
one of the benefits of going to these
big name brand colleges is the
networking is the exposure to elements
of society that you would not otherwise
be exposed to so
why why is it so important
take the libs Arguments for a second why
is it so important that poor kids from
the inner city who never had a leg up
are given special privileges to go to a
place like Harvard
is it so that they can study calculus
is it so that they can read
Dickens
no you can do that anywhere the reason
it's so important the whole argument for
affirmative action in the first place is
that Harvard is an elite institution
that disproportionately has influence on
American public life and so
we want people who have been kept out of
the elite to be given
a a pass to get into the elite to
refresh the elite and to help improve
their lot in life that's the whole
argument for affirmative action well
what what makes Harvard Elite
yeah maybe a little bit is the
professors yeah maybe it's a little bit
the dorms are nice or something like
that but the real thing is that it's the
people that you're interacting with the
old wealthy
families whose names you've heard of who
have influence in Banks and media and
politics and education or all of these
institutions and when you are injected
into that Society
then you
you gain an advantage and you have an
easier time becoming a member of that
Elite
whether that's still true today whether
or not Harvard and Yale and Princeton
have lost a little bit of their luster
that's a question for another time
that's at least the the idea for
affirmative action and so if that is the
case
then you need legacy admissions if that
is the if the whole point is the hobnob
with the fancy wealthy people you know
the I don't know the Rockefellers and
the the bushes and all these kinds of
people and the Kennedys you know then
you need legacy admissions to hobnob
with them
no you might say well no Harvard's just
going to admit the people with the
highest test scores well there's more to
life than test scores there's more to
Human Society than
meritocracy
you still need the people who own the
companies to be involved you still need
the people who own the land to be
involved you still need people with
stakes in government with influence to
be involved Society is about a lot more
than just how you did on your sat
furthermore pure meritocracy is not
especially conservative because another
thing that legacy admissions do
beyond the arguments that if that even
the affirmative action proponents would
make for legacy admissions is they
provide stability
they encourage affection for
institutions when when you've been going
to Harvard for 12 Generations you're
gonna have a great deal of affection for
Harvard you're probably going to give
more money to Harvard that money that
you give to Harvard is going to pay for
the scholarship students by the way so
it's going to to help the meritocracy in
some ways and it's going to make sure
that those bonds of affection keep the
people who have the greatest interest in
preserving these institutions around for
the longest period of time
there's going to be stability there if
you're great great great great
granddaddy went to an institution your
family's been on there for a long time
then you're going to know things that
you can't put in an admissions brochure
or in a training session you're gonna
you're gonna know the nooks and the
crannies and the ins and the outs of the
place the ineffable little aspects of an
institution that give the institution
its particularity and make it lovable
and make it unique uh
and then furthermore
you're you're going to have
a
certain
a certain enduring stability to the
place
things that just don't change you know
there was always this conflict in GOP
fundraisers in the last 30 years let's
say where you'd have the first part
you'd you'd hear about the importance of
family values
and then in the second part of the GOP
fundraiser speech you'd hear about the
importance of creative destruction and
how we just need to change everything
all the time and constantly innovate
those things are opposed to one another
one of the I guess the central feature
of a legacy admission is family
the idea that you and your brother are
going to go to the same college and
maybe maybe it doesn't it's not a
guaranteed way of entry into a college
but if that if your brother goes there
and your sister goes there and your
father went there then you're going to
have an advantage to getting in there
too isn't it good don't we want families
to remain tightly knit doesn't that
doesn't that provide a good stable
building block for society isn't that a
deeply conservative value
it is and
I guess I have a particular bit of
credibility here because it wasn't a
legacy admission and my family didn't go
to any of these places and I didn't come
for money and we didn't donate money to
build a building on campus or anything
like that and so I I just can see it
from the outside
and
it's it's like with anything in society
that the Liberals have through envy and
resentment and pride tried to knock down
they they failed to see even three feet
ahead of them and they fail to see how
these institutions that they resent and
envy
help them and when you knock down the
legacy admissions you're going to knock
down the advantages that these people
are are seeking up to and including
their own scholarships that are going to
let that are going to let them
in
now all of that said
Harvard's a pretty rotten place and if
Harvard crumbles
I'm not going to shed a whole lot of
Tears for it
a lot of the American Elite institutions
have been so rotted out by the left that
if they crumble I'm not going to be all
that upset about it
but
I don't want when those institutions do
crumble I don't want these people to say
that I didn't tell them so
now speaking of nepo babies
I guess I guess I'll just have to tease
the story maybe we'll get to it tomorrow
a certain substance was found in the
White House they found a white powder
and another white powder scares that
happen often in politics and when white
powder is found anywhere in someone's
mailbox this just happened with state
legislators here in Tennessee you know
the the emergency teams are called in
they've got to test the pattern people
are evacuated so there's this big
emergency at the White House we've got
to get out of here there was there was
white powder found in the residence
the white powder was found just shortly
after Hunter Biden paid a visit to the
residents and I think you know where
this is going here let's just say wasn't
Anthrax we don't know who the white
powder belonged to
but it would appear to be some of that
grade a hunter-esque booger sugar found
in the White House residents
we will
get to that story tomorrow I guess today
we finally get back to the member block
even though producer Jacob
not given me my iPad yet I know that
it's work Wednesday because we had
Monday it was July 3rd yesterday was the
4th of July so now I finally get to be
with you again here on work Wednesday if
producer Jacob ever gets me my beautiful
iPad the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Noel yes I check it for
two months free on all annual plans
foreign
[Music]